three games tomorrow texans going to
detroit followed by washington dallas
and then the nightcap the steelers and
the ravens some props for the games most
passing yards for the day desean watson
or the field any of the other
quarterbacks well i mean to me it's that
game though it's desean watson or matt
stafford it's one of those two i mean
first off
both defenses can't defend the past so
there's issues there um
but you can't pick the lion i'm going to
sean watson i'm taking him over the
field i am the way he played last week
the really the way he's played here as
of late and you know they seem to have
gotten something together on the
offensive side of the ball yeah i'm
going to take him against that lions
team this is the kind of game desean
watson it might be it's gonna be a lot
of fun to watch i think he could take
over you know just not enough talent in
that front to contain him and do things
just like we saw last week a little with
the patriots and then his throwing is as
good as it gets so i'm gonna go with
them
when you're not really playing for
anything this becomes kind of a bowl
game right yeah thanksgiving day
right lifelong dream this is the only
thing that still stands out on the
schedule other than sliding into spoiler
mode in december which
yeah it's not as fun as feeling like
you're in a big spot on a big day and
you want to perform for everybody who's
home watching that's right and i'm i
want to disagree with you just to make
it interesting but i'm looking at the
other names and it's like yeah who can i
credibly say would have more passing
yards and desean watson given the
circumstances they're going to to face
on thursday all right the most rushing
yards let's do the same thing ezekiel to
the cowboys or the field well this is a
little more complex here first off
you know ezekiel elliott and that that
washington defense come on now i mean
that that washington front is the real
deal i don't know if you know just the
the common fan the washington defense is
a top 10 defense in football it's pretty
damn special that way
i i think
no i'm not i'm going with the field on
this one i'm not going to pick ezekiel
first off i think the running back on
the other side of the ball for the the
washington team
could have a big day and antonio gibson
against that that dallas defense and i'm
not going to forget gus edwards and the
ravens either i mean let's not forget
gus edwards and the ravens at all them
they
like what was it 250 60 yards the last
time they played pittsburgh as far as
running the ball so i could see him
having a big day too um so i'm going
with the field on this one i'm not going
with zeke
yeah i am too and it may be some names
you're not even thinking about you just
never know who's going to pop up and be
the star on thanksgiving it could be
lamar jackson
definitely could be you're right there's
no doubt no doubt okay
most receiving yards for thanksgiving
will fuller at detroit terry mclaren at
dallas or deontay johnson against the
ravens i guess there are others that
would be candidates let's just focus on
those three yeah all three i mean all
three are going to have unbelievable
opportunities that's for sure and you
know the the football team washington
you know their main focus in the past
game is to get terry mcclure in the ball
he's the only guy that really scares you
of their group fuller is going to have
matchups detroit plays a lot of
man-to-man and deontay johnson against
baltimore man he's going to get a lot of
man-to-man on an island with marlon hump
humphrey or or marcus peters type looks
either as well i'm going to go with will
fuller i am
um
i want to terry mccorman is the best of
the bunch
mccorn is one of those guys that really
probably needs to be talked about as a
top 10 receiver in football
uh but i guess i get scared of that just
a little bit because alex smith can be
not the best deep ball thrower not be
aggressive that way and i think i'll go
with fuller because of watson and that
poor lions
defense fuller i should say yeah yeah i
i just i can't put i can't just with
fuller i'ma i'm just always worried
about when he's gonna get injured i'll
go mclaren
just uh because he's on both of my
fantasy teams not that anyone cares well
always pulling for terry mcclure in this
show well yeah i mean he's fun to watch
he really is i mean he's he's one of
those guys like we talk about tyree kill
and dk i mean there's there's three
rockets up his butt it's not two it's
three i mean he can fly and you know you
look at deontay johnson what he's doing
for the steelers you know to your point
with what you just said with the running
backs with the steelers it's hard you
know you don't know in a game like this
last time chase claypool didn't didn't
he had a handful of touchdowns against
the ravens you know chase claypool could
be the guy you just don't know who
that's going to be in pittsburgh right
now it's kind of what makes them cool
they have a few guys who you know can
step up to the plate on a given week i
just have to ask because i had heard the
phrase rock it up his butt before
before working with you it's a football
term you're the one that's expanded it
to two or three are you on like a star
system they're like what's the maximum
either four is it five or is it just no
i think three three is only for a
special group that's like you know the
daryl green deon sanders terry mclaurin
you know tyree killed the special guys
that you'd go
they could be the fastest in football
though those guys have three rockets up
their butt guys like dk metcalf maybe
and jaylen ramsey they only got two even
though they can fly there's only two
all right well now that i understand
that i'll be on the lookout for the
players who qualify for the triple
triple rocket in the uh in ill and or up
the butt all right which team will score
the most points on thanksgiving points
bet has the over unders at houston 27
detroit 24
washington 21 and a half dallas 24 and a
half baltimore 19 and a half in
pittsburgh 24 and a half who do you
think will score the most i mean i i
hate to say it again it's just i i look
at houston as being the team that's
going to put up points
more than not yeah i have a hard time
not
going anywhere else i just can't trust
dallas quite yet that way
washington we know they play a certain
style then baltimore and pittsburgh with
as good as those defenses are and things
like that you know it's hard so there
yeah i'm going to go with houston once
again
i don't want to give in too much to
recency bias although i seem to all the
time but if the lions were just shut out
20 to nothing
by a former houston roughnecks
xfl quarterback
i think the current houston texans nfl
quarterback will have his way with that
team and it just feels like the lions
currently are teetering a little bit so
i agree with you i think the texans will
score the most points it's amazing the
superlatives were heaping on a team that
has a record of three and seven and
seems to be mired in dysfunction that's
what beating the patriots will do for
you all of a sudden people view your
franchise differently i'm gonna go off
the board i got one more prop okay who
okay tonight
who smashes more
fruit and or gourds is it mccarthy with
watermelons or is it ron rivera with
pumpkins he suggested yesterday he may
smash some pumpkins tonight to get his
guys fired up as an answer to what mike
mccarthy did over the weekend when he
went gallagher with a sledgehammer on
watermelons oh uh so you want to know
who's gonna do more than who's going to
do more damage tonight two more to get
the team fired up rivera mccarthy i'm
going to mccarthy i'm going with
mccarthy here i think mccarthy is like
you know probably at a boiling point
anyways with just all the crap that's
gone on well
yeah i'm gonna still go with him just
trying to get his team motivated to play
all those type of things i'll go with
him smashing more watermelons
oh god i forgot jack del rio
is currently on the washington staff
please hey ron if if if he brings in a
tree stump tell him get that thing the
hell out of here no chopping wood in the
locker room that did not end well if you
recall chris chris hansen punter for the
jaguars decided after del rio put a tree
stump a real tree stump in the locker
room with an axe in it inviting the
players to chop wood as
a
literal example of the keep chopping
wood mantra for the season chris hanson
the punter of the team chopped his leg
with the
the uh uh axe how does that didn't chop
it off but uh he did a serious
laceration to his leg while trying to
chop the the uh like really so how do
you do that i i gotta get the scouting
report on that we need to maybe call
chris hanson he seems like a good guy he
might give us the actual i mean how do
you miss this i don't know i don't even
know how do you get in the position to
hit your own leg with an axe
you may be surprised by this but i've
swung an axe or two in my time yeah it
has a lot of weight at the end and once
it goes it goes and you can't stop it
so you think he just lost control and
something like i think he just lost
control of it and it it swings like a
pendulum or as you used to say pendulum
from your wrist sounds good it just goes
it just goes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports